so the other thing I'd like to say about
this is where the media anxiously
waiting on all this information about
the shooter how about we have a a
blackout on the shooters and what they
did you know this is uh
[Applause]
yesterday
was the opening of the baseball season
now in baseball when somebody runs on
the field the camera doesn't show it
they don't give that person any
publicity why can't we at least do that
in this country I don't want to hear
anything about it we know what happened
I don't want to know about I don't want
to know that what orientation this
person is how old they are what their
Manifesto said I don't give a about
any of it because it's just going to
inspire the next one because they all
feed on each other that's true at least
the media could do
yeah except that I think the horror of
it you know that that there were three
children involved and then of course the
adults and and that lives were just
taken just like that without any purpose
behind it without there was no warning
there there's a shock to your system
but once you you set that aside yes
um then you then then let's not keep
talking about it I don't want to hear
what the manifesto is because some other
idiot will come along and try to improve
upon whatever that is and I think Bill
if we can keep here's the thing if we
can keep people from getting on planes
without guns then surely we can do that
in the school system
we can do that we have the technology
let's get it done that's the first order
of business well well it takes like an
hour and a half to get on a plane are
you saying that we should be doing life
is worth it if you're saying the kids
should have to go through security for
it out like and take off their shoes on
their belt and put them in the thing
every day to go into school
armed guards and their other yes
measures that are necessary because look
you're never going to get rid of the 400
million guns in this country whether you
want to or not it's impossible it would
spark a civil war if you tried to
confiscate them all so what I think is
going to happen bad people will always
get guns always that's the thing because
you know what they're not giving up
their guns because they're the bad
people they're the bad people yes just
like the drugs we have a War on Drugs we
can't get rid of them Bill they're still
coming across the border well thank God
for that but uh
the guns
that go well in this state marijuana is
legal well hey remember I'm from Jamaica
where is that bill